[Musique]
bonjour gilbert roger merci beaucoup
d'être un jour avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france alors vous êtes
sénateur vous avez vu le premier
ministre est fière voilà ce qu'il a dit
pas de confinement pour l'instant pas
nécessaire écoutez on en parle après
dans l'absolu le confinement n'est pas
exclu en dernier recours mais les
chiffres à ce jour nous laisse à penser
que le couvre-feu suffit alors un couvre
feu qui pourrait être étendue à tout le
territoire couvre-feu avancé à 18h qu'en
pensez vous je suis assez réservé
personnellement sur cette avancée du
couvre feu
je pense que on continue à concentrer
des déplacements concentré l'obligation
pour les gens d'aller faire leurs
courses de récupérer les enfants à
l'école et presque de limiter les
activités que les enfants peuvent avoir
en culture à en sport donc je trouve que
ça n'est pas une bonne idée moi je suis
pour le développement xxl de la
vaccination comme le gouvernement
patauge lamentablement
il est en train de revenir sur des
histoires de confinement parce que il
est incapable en réalité de distribuer
rapidement et de faire vacciner le
maximum de de notre population quels que
soient les âges
il faut y aller alors c'est vrai que la
france a dépassé le cap des cent mille
vacciner ça reste peut effectivement
comparée à nos voisins européens avec de
fortes disparités en fonction des
régions
c'est ce qu'on constate qu alors que
pensez vous de cette stratégie vaccinale
on a un début de réponse de votre part
olivier verrons qui est auditionné
justement aujourd'hui à l'assemblée et
au sénat
qu'est ce que vous allez lui poser comme
question je pense que les questions que
vont poser mes collègues et moi je suis
à la commission affaires étrangères et
défense
les que les collègues qui sont dans
cette dans la commission compétente vont
poser les questions de pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à amener les vaccins jusque
au plus proche de nos concitoyens pour
qu'ils se fassent vacciner et qu'on
arrête un peu c'est tortueuse circulaire
qui complexifie au maximum la
vaccination
on a l'expérience possible de la façon
dont on vaccine les gens pour la grille
alors mettons la même procédure
moi je connais des gens changent que
donner l'exemple mon propre père qu'il
ya 90 ans n'a pas reçu de feuilles de la
sécurité sociale pour se faire vacciner
il est en pleine forme de swallow et il
peut se déplacer est autonome il attend
mais il attend quoi il n'en sait rien
puisque rien ne lui ai dit c'est ce que
disent certains élus locaux également ce
manque d'informations en tout cas est
perceptible au niveau local oui on a les
conférences qui sont faites avec les
préfets toutes les semaines j'avais sel
dans mon département vendredi soir
dernier
mais qu'est ce qu'il advient c'est une
litanie expliqué de la politique
ministérielle
donc on oublie une circulaire qui dit
tel jour à telle heure on sera autorisé
à ouvrir un centre de vaccination à
l'hôpital d'aulnay et puis on va
contacter les gens mais comment est ce
qu'on les contacts est bien c'est qu'on
prend pas la tâche de l'asepam en pas la
tâche des collectivités locales pour
préparer les gens à dire prenez rendez
vous voilà comment vous pouvez le faire
on a mis en place une sorte
d'application la colline
stop coville mais c'est là dessus que le
gouvernement devrait mettre une
application permettant à chaque citoyen
de pouvoir prendre rang pour se faire
vacciner
et s'il faut commencer par les gens de
75 ans et plus et bien qu'ils aient un
petit message dit vous êtes en attente
revenez reconnecter vous dans dix jours
parce qu'on va on va peut-être prendre
d'autres tranches d'âge
voyez ces on met des choses et puis là
voilà on assomme monsieur castex a
inventé un comité citoyen de 35
personnes tirées au sort mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette affaire alors
justement qui doit décider qui doit
décider qui doit débattre nouveau
conseil de défense on l'a vu ils se
succèdent cette semaine avec les parents
dévoués que les parlementaires hier
boycottée par la france insoumise qui
dit que c'est à l'assemblée de débattre
de cette question est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
oui et le gouvernement et le président
de la république méprise complètement le
parlement le sénat comme l'assemblée
nationale c'est inadmissible ces lattes
la démocratie se joue et c'est là que
les ministres doivent rendre des comptes
ils n'ont pas à le faire ailleurs et
donc effectivement tous ces comités
théodule c'est du brouillard pour éviter
peut-être le rendez-vous qu'il faudrait
avoir avec ce gouvernement pour le
mettre en responsabilité devant nous
extension de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
également jusqu'en juin un commentaire
ouais je commence à être réservés autant
chez à chaque fois voté pour et et sans
arrière pensée autant là je commence à
m'interroger parce que je ne comprends
pas je ne sais pas lire du castex dans
le texte
voilà et donc il faudrait peut-être que
on apprenne à parler le même langage et
ce monsieur visiblement ne connaît pas
les codes du sénat en particulier on va
parler de la situation en seine saint
denis
puisque vous êtes sénateur on a vu dans
cette matinale la détresse de certains
étudiants face à la crise sanitaire
une partie de la jeunesse qui bascule
dans la précarité le président du
conseil départemental de
seine-saint-denis a publié cette semaine
une tribune regarder pour réclamer
l'extension du rsa aux moins de 25 ans
alors que la précarité des étudiants a
explosé nous appelons les responsables
des universités présentes en
seine-saint-denis à ce que soit enfin
ouvert le rsa aux moins de 25 ans
il ne reste pas beaucoup de temps mais
qu'elle est quel est votre point de vue
sur cette question cruciale de la de la
jeunesse saine je laisse il faut lui
donner de l'espoir c'est pour ça qu'il
faut lui permettre aussi d'être vacciné
pour retourner sur les bancs de
l'université
et pour être en permanence sur les bancs
des lycées collèges et puis il sort
excusez moi gilbert roger les le vaccin
ne protège pas contre la propagation du
virus est ce que ce ne sont pas plutôt
les professeurs qu'il faut vacciner
il faut les oui bien sûr c'est le milieu
de l'éducation donc les professeurs
aussi il faut que on le voit bien avec
le bas de sa grille plus on al de jean
bad ciné - la grippe circulent
les derniers exemples les dernières
statistiques le montrent donc allons-y
allons-y fortement je comprends pas que
en israël
en allemagne même au royaume uni on voit
qu'on est en capacité de de vacciner
vite et fort et que nous on est en train
de chercher les lieux on va mettre des
lieux de vaccination
merci beaucoup gilbert roger d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france